how did some hits notify you dude I got
a call but I had made that I made the
film we you know we were I think I think
Trevor said this when he introduced the
film publicly that I think we were the
the only movie to the no movie has ever
wrapped shooting in November and played
the festival in January so we had a
really fast post-production process I'm
my own editor I run post on my movie so
I was able to pull it off you know but
it was one of those things where we
submitted a rough cotton I didn't have
to wait that long because they were
having to lock their schedule I was just
lucky they even were able to watch it
still you know cuz they were still
watching a handful of straggling films
that were coming in and I was able to
get get a rough version of my movie and
so I didn't I don't I didn't have to
wait I had to wait less than a week but
still when I got the call it was um if
we're felt really good was that I not
knowing what it felt like to not get in
which hit me too hard the first time
that this time around I told myself was
like I'm just submitting because i put
the film I knew I was innocent in the
film for a year I knew I tried other
festivals if we if we add even when we
were shooting the film I didn't think
we're gonna get a chance to even place
on dance because I just think the timing
would work out um and so for me when I
found out that there would still be
enough time for me to put a rough edit
together for them to screen I thought
I'm submitting for myself I'm not
submitting for even the movie I'm just
submitting to know I did my best in the
time I had I didn't sleep for a week and
I got an added to get you know that kind
of thing I I did my best in that time so
I at the end of the day I couldn't feel
like well maybe what if you know that
that feeling you know I did I wouldn't
regret not trying for it so ultimately
submitting the movie for me it felt more
cathartic and I was I was expecting to
not get in a lot of ways um and so
getting in felt really good and the call
came from Trevor who you know he saved
kind of saved my first film you have all
the festivals all the major festivals
have passed on it and he was running
Senate Vegas at the same time he was
running Sundance and so he had seen it
at Sundance because they had really
considered it and one of the strangest
moments for me and talking about
Sundance was when John Cooper introduced
the premiere of co ji you know he talked
about how it still haunted him to not
program easier practice which was like
really humbling and really nice to hear
and a lot of ways to know that they
really did
you know consider it and mine was one of
those like we were talking about before
mine was a totally blind submission I
didn't know anyone in the festival but
all in my first film so here I got that
close is is really overwhelming and and
and so getting the call from Trevor
who's been one of the most supportive
people to me it just meant a lot I had
like the weight of like ears on it you
know sort of had the weight of no one
wanting this film to get made its in
some strange way you know you don't want
to look to the festival to give you
validation but what the one thing it
does nice it doesn't give you personal
validation it gives I'll addition to
everyone else you know for everyone else
is a shorthand it's kind of like the
same way the Spirit Awards was it's like
for me like winning awards and stuff it
doesn't really mean anything to me
personally but what it means is
something for the movie and it means
something for like my ability to keep on
making movies because it's shorthand for
people so people like well I didn't
really like it that much but it played
Sunday and so there must be something
great good about it you know people use
it as like a litmus test for better or
worse it's one of the advantages of it
so for me it was it felt really good I
mean it was really and also like I was
at the very tail end of working every
day because we went it was like we were
financed in August and we prepped in
September we shot in October and part of
November I cut it in november we found
out we got in late November you know was
one of those things where it was like I
need sleet and then it was like I had to
cut that I had like a less than a month
the lock picture and then posed and the
two days later we premiered the movie so
it was literally one long stream of like
five months four months of just a
non-stop work every day of the week so
it was sort of a culmination of that and
all that sort of apex with me getting
the sickest i've been maybe in my entire
life of not at least a decade when in
sunday's cuz like my body just like shut
down from all the hard work but it was
but it was really i mean it was it was a
it was a great feeling and it you know
it was really nice to have their support
it was
you